back happy one year anniversary to soul
belly barbecue rocky is there live
getting a taste of how you can celebrate
with them this weekend rocky what are
you eating
jillian i'm already eating i was just
telling chef bruce i i did not eat lunch
because i knew i was coming here and it
was time to dig in i was trying to throw
down for the birthday okay so i'm
already eating the mac and cheese but
chef bruce curious we'll talk to you in
a second about desserts but
chef bruce let's talk about the menu and
how it's special for sunday celebration
so it's really special i have i'm really
excited because i've got some amazing
guests coming to cook with us
we have andre james from the raiders the
starting center of the raiders you know
i connected with him at one point and we
shared his love for barbecue and he
likes to smoke meat so i know he's
cooking beef ribs that's all i i want to
keep some of it a little bit of a secret
surprise but so you have a raider chef
well no i know
the raider player is the chef and he's
going to be here cooking for the guest
on sunday that's dope yeah he's and he's
a cool guy you know he loves barbecue um
i have a couple of the the guys from
austin that on the texas monthly top 50
list coming um evan leroy from lauren
lewis and i've got john bates from
interstellar bbq both amazing guys
incredible barbecue what's cool about
the barbecue community is that everybody
just comes together it's not about
competition it's everybody's together
right even the competitions are all
about togetherness so
it's about smoking meat slow hanging out
drinking some beer yeah you know talking
smack and and having a good time so and
then i have uh bert bachmann from sly
barbecue in la is a good friend of mine
and my favorite person right here karis
kawana she's going to be doing putting
together an incredible dessert display
and then we're going to pass around a
bunch of our food from soul belly and
have cups of mac and cheese some banana
pudding cups
um we're gonna be passing some other
meats probably some sausage something
like that i don't know
well you said we want to keep the menu
somewhat of a secret so you guys got to
come down on sunday to actually see
what's going on so let's move over here
to charis now because you right before
right before the show she was putting
her bacon on her brownies because these
are not just basic brownies okay
definitely not i wanted all the desserts
to be very very special to a bruce
because he's been a great addition to
downtown and uh not only i didn't want
to just do sweets i wanted to do a
little bit of savory just for him so
we've got some bacon brownies i'm making
some brisket brittle that'll be really
cool mac and cheese ice cream
mac and cheese ice cream girl you can't
just say that you can't just say that
you please explain please explain
you gotta come down and check it out for
yourself and actually it's pretty darn
popular
i've got some chicken feet gummies and
some some piggy gummies that are just
for the kids and i promise you it'll be
a lot of fun oh my gosh this is my first
bacon brownie
how is it not bad that was delicious i
think wow salt has a lot to do with uh
carrots
yeah yeah
she's incredible yeah and like she
helped me with some of the stuff here
actually the banana pudding she helped
inspire that recipe uh we're very good
friends and we've been working together
for a minute and and everything that she
makes is
incredible such a family here you guys i
love it here i love it here so tell
everybody how they can come celebrate
you guys on sunday with you and the
guest chefs and everything it's a party
so you can go um on our instagram
soulbellybqlv
uh you can go on mine which is chef b
kalman and there's a ticket link or you
can just go to eventbrite and look it up
uh tickets are 50 bucks for food and fun
this will be live music and then we've
got some drink samples going on and then
we have our full our full bar with a few
special cocktails as well that we put
together yeah i see the bacon in the
cocktail okay that you can't do a
bourbon without bacon no [ __ ] belly
no it's a it's actually a bacon infused
bourbon garrison brothers bourbon that
we're turned into an old-fashioned it's
really good and we make the bacon here
so it's just everything we try to do is
very special yeah i can tell i can tell
i love it here okay you guys have to
come down sunday celebrating one year at
seoul belly is going to be a party i'll
send it back to you
please bring us back one of those bacon
brownies you took the words out of my
mouth i was just about to say i wouldn't
be mad if she brought back one of those
bacon brownies
look amazing
that looks great all right let's send it
over to ted